[Musique]
dans l'actualité de ce 23 mars et le
tape du poing sur la table neuf
associations de protection de
l'environnement ont décidé de s'allier
pour protester contre plusieurs projets
urbains yvelinois et des chantiers
portés par des entreprises privées et le
département des yvelines
la trente cinquième course du coeur
c'est lens ce soir de paris direction au
bourg saint maurice les arcs avec un
passage par les yvelines dans la nuit
750 km de course en relais pour
sensibiliser au don d'organes d'ailleurs
l'une des équipes engagées contre des
coureurs transplantés parmi eux un
yvelinois damien berthet que nous avons
pu suivre lors de sa préparation et puis
découverte de ce système il permet de
fixer un fauteuil roulant une
trottinette électrique le prototype a
été développé par une entreprise
francilienne ce qui lui a permis de
remporter le concours lépine 2021
expérimentation dans cette édition à
montigny le bretonneux
[Musique]
saint-exupéry à mantes la jolie en tête
du classement des lycées dans les
yvelines c'est le palmarès 2022 établi
par nos confrères du parisien qui le
révèle en 2021 l'établissement qui
compte un tiers d'élèves issus de
quartiers prioritaires totalisait 95 %
de réussite au bac dont 65% avec mention
saint-exupéry propose également des
enseignements originaux comme des cours
de cinéma d'audiovisuel ou de théâtre et
de musique et à nouer des partenariats
avec sciences po paris et l'école
normale supérieure dans le top 10 le
lycée militaire de saint cyr l'école et
condorcet à limay complète le podium
suivi de la plaine 2 nov la trappe et de
notre dame du grand champ à versailles
unique structure privée du top 10 mantes
la jolie place un deuxième lycée parmi
les dix premiers jean rostand et 10e
pour établir son classement le parisien
prend en compte de critères la
différence entre les résultats obtenus
et ceux attendus au bac ainsi que le
taux d'accompagnement des élèves par le
rétablissement de la seconde à la
terminale
[Musique]
elle passe un cap plusieurs associations
de protection de l'environnement
saisisse la justice elles sont neuf à
s'unir pour demander l'annulation de
plusieurs projets ports industriels
projets routiers dans les yvelines les
associations dit stop en fait on est sur
un territoire où les projets sont
conduits sans vraiment prendre en compte
l'avis des citoyens et aujourd'hui on se
rend compte que ces projets ne
correspond plus aux besoins du
territoire effectivement l'union fait la
force mais aussi la compétence c'est à
dire quoi on a des associations agréées
de l'environnement on a des associations
qui se battent sur des points très
particulier jeudi 17 mars se tenait
l'audience concernant le port de
triel-sur-seine à la cour administrative
d'appel de versailles porté par aropa
ports de paris ce projet souhaite
assurer une desserte fluviale de la
boucle de chanteloup déjà ce qu'on
reproche en premier lieu à port de paris
soit le mans d'avoir essayé de mentir
aux habitants peu sur la réalité des
activités qu'ils allaient être
accueillis sur ce port et les nuisances
qui pouvait en résulter de la bonne
nouvelle c'est que le rapporteur public
a conclu à l'annulation de la
déclaration d'intérêt général et de
l'arrêté préfectoral ce qui veut dire
que comme les juges du premier degré
bien on s'oriente probablement
aujourd'hui vers l'annulation définitive
de ce projet les neuf associations
requérantes sont soutenus par le
collectif alternative en vallée de seine
qui regroupe une trentaine
d'associations
elles ont aussi décidé de faire appel à
des avocats spécialistes des causes
environnementales c'est un combat si
vous voulez nécessaire contre la
bétonisation des rives de la seine s'ils
voulaient cirque on a l'impression qu'on
construit des ports des projets
industriels terre la seule réponse qui
est donné de l'autre côté c'est
construire construire construire
construire sans nécessairement répondre
à un besoin donc moi je trouve qu'il ya
un moment il faut se poser se dire voilà
quel est l'intérêt des populations de
l'environnement est ce qu'il est
nécessaire de construire encore un tort
parmi les autres projets contestés la
construction d'un pont entre hr et
carrières sous poissy pourquoi mauvais
projet parce qu'il est effectivement
dans laxe de la francilienne qui va
amener toute une circulation dans la
boucle de chanteloup qui n'a qu'un seul
exutoire quel point de triel qui est un
pont récent réalisé aussi par le
département comme quoi le département
aime bien les ponts mais qui en fait ne
débouche que sur l'a13 pour le moment
les associations ont déposé plusieurs
requêtes en annulation contre les
projets du port d'achères et la
requalification de l'art départementale
190 entre carrières sous poissy et triel
sur seine d'autres projets pourraient
être attaquées dans les mois à venir
[Musique]
elle était prévue le 16 mars dernier en
visioconférence mais n'avait pas pu se
tenir suite un problème technique la
réunion publique sur la modification du
plan local d'urbanisme intercommunal de
saint quentin en yvelines est reporté
elle se tiendra le mardi 29 mars en
présentiel et sera accessible à tous
débuts fixé à 19 heures dans la salle du
conseil communautaire à trappes l
agglomération a mis en ligne une vidéo
et un support de présentation montrant
les modifications prévues dans le pays
et lui
[Musique]
greffer de la moelle osseuse en octobre
2018 à la suite d'une leucémie damien
berthet est l'un des douze coureurs
transplantés qui va participer à la
course du coeur organisé par
l'association transforme une association
qui promeut le sport chez les personnes
greffées la course solidaire regroupera
160 personnes 750 km de course à pied en
fin de course de vélo et de roller en
relève on a une première étape en ile de
france
et ensuite
donc ça c'est sur quatre jours et quatre
nuits pour terminer ensuite à bourg
saint maurice le dimanche midi et on
célèbre la montée à des harkis les 15 à
24 km la ville mais des dénivelés fondé
deux personnes au fait de la moelle est
majoritairement c'est donc des greffes
de foie des greffes de rein on a entre
29 et 78 une course à un objectif
sensibiliser le grand public au don
d'organes et de tissus en france donc il
ya soixante trois mille personnes qui
sont à greffer
25 ou 27 mai qui sont en attente de
greffe et dans mon cas précis le don de
moelle osseuse est un don du vivant donc
j'ai envie de faire partager tout le
monde peut s'inscrire il suffit d'aller
dans un fr avoir moins de 35 ans et
s'inscrire sur le registre international
des dons d'un molosse ne plus courir
pour montrer que l'activité sportive est
possible suite à une transplantation une
évidence pour ce coureur qui a commencé
à courir il y a dix ans dans le cas d'un
d'une greffe ou dans le cas d'un cancer
comme le mien en fait le
l'activité sportive donc permet aux
greffons de bien s'implanter permet de
garder un beau slogan still de vies et
de réduire en fait de 40 % le risque de
rechute par exemple pour moi pour mon
concert quand on était enfermé pendant
quatre semaines 4 x 4 semaines dans les
jambes stérile qu'on savait pas si on
allait ressortir la première fois c'est
on en profite donc au fil de la vie la
course du coeur passera par les yvelines
dans la nuit du 23 au 24 mars elle
traversera 200 communes françaises
durant son parcours
[Musique]
en faisant ça on a plus l'impression
qu'on est rentré on est on est dans le
même monde que les valides en fait des
trottinettes électriques pour fauteuil
roulant c'est la solution de déplacement
proposé par la société omis plus de 500
personnes à mobilité réduite ont d'ores
et déjà adopté valider le concept régis
harel ont fait partie voir se déplacer
d'un point à un point b par exemple sont
à 3 4 kilomètres à faire dans ton normal
on aurait pris mon fauteuil je ralentir
la voiture j'aurais fait un transfert là
on prend la trottinette plaque au monde
dessus ont la tâche on est parti et
c'est efficace la seule difficulté c'est
de faire en fait du du deux roues de
passer par le sida d'un la roue arrière
de la trottinette après je vais poser là
sur le système et je vais juste reculé
comme ça et ça y est ça s'enclenche
automatiquement
voilà c'est tout ce que j'ai eu à faire
à saint quentin en yvelines et grâce aux
subventions de l'agglomération louer une
trottinette revient entre 45 et 75 euros
par mois le plus si la solution est
approuvée au bout de deux ans la
trottinette et céder aux locataires pour
un euro symbolique nous à chaque fois
qu'on fait quelque chose en gros il faut
un truc spécifique qui va coûter très
cher et tout parce que là c'est quelque
chose qui coûte pas très cher primé au
concours d'invention lépine 2020 les
deux modèles proposés permettent
l'optimisation des trajets de distance
moyenne en autonomie avec la seule que
j'ai pris on peut compter une trentaine
de kilomètres donc ça fait pas mal
davantage avec ses trottinette aussi
c'est que pour monter les côtes on monte
plus facilement les côtes qu'avec une
roue électrique devant parce que la
production se fait par l'arrière langer
ça a été pouvoir s'adapter justement à
toutes ces géométriques fauteuil et tout
en ayant quelque chose qui soit super
rapides à mettre au quotidien quand on
veut faire des trottinettes après deux
ans de recherche et développement la
société omni a lancé le produit l'année
dernière il suffit de quelques tutos
explicatifs pour pouvoir commencer
l'utilisation sur le fauteuil la
trottinette elle peut aussi être
utilisée par des valides et donc il ya
on me dit dans quel rapprocher des roues
qui empêche la elle le risque de
crevaison et des francs pour renforcer
la sécurité et freinage en cas de
question il suffit de contacter la
société via son site internet à terme
omis aimerait démocratiser ce mode en
sport et effacer la frontière entre
personnes à mobilité réduite est valide
[Musique]
pink mobilité est une entreprise qui
développe qui produit et qui
commercialise des scooters électriques
nous existons depuis 2016 et nous avons
trois marchés principaux premièrement le
marché de la livraison du dernier
kilomètre donc c'est les pizzas les
sushis voilà le deuxième marché c'est le
marché de la mobilité partagée le
scooter en libre-service
est le troisième marché c'est le marché
des particuliers dans nos gammes de
scooter on a aussi un scooter pour le
qui est conçu pour le libre service et
on a conçu ce scooter là et on l'a
amélioré depuis plus de trois ans
quasiment quatre ans maintenant pour
cette société qui s'appelle diego
[Musique]
le premier poste et jonathan qu'il tient
ici on fait tout ce qui est câblage vers
installations mécaniques sur le scooter
et liaison avec tous les câbles du
scooter le deuxième poste
est un poste vrai manque les dents sur
la ligne de production c'est un poste
sur lequel on vous a continué de monter
certains composants électroniques il
faut savoir que cette ligne de
production d'adame paix cet été pour
produire jusqu'à 30 scooter par jour on
vient vérifier également car les tests
électroniques pour vérifier que tout
fonctionne depuis notant les feux klaxon
etc on vient effectué tous les contrôles
mécanique du scooter donc vérifier le
serrage au couple d
des vagues de roue on vient remonter les
bernier carénage du scooter
fixer les rétroviseurs le support de
téléphone m les casques dans le caisson
arrière quand on roule en électrique on
a vraiment cette sensation un peu de
voix là de liberté parce qu'on n'est pas
polluer ni par l'odeur ni par le bruit
du moteur ni par les vibrations avec un
scooter électrique vous avez la batterie
à payer donc la batterie ça coûte plus
cher qu'un réservoir d'essence vide vous
allez investir un peu plus au départ
mais derrière vous n'allez rien payer ni
en essence vous allez payer beaucoup
moins cher en entretien on a des villes
qui sont de plus en plus congestionnées
il ya deux pleins d'embouteillage et
c'est donc évidemment c'est plus c'est
plus efficient et c'est plus valorisant
de se dire que ont conduit un produit
qui est plus efficient qui moins polluer
si on est par hasard bloqué dans un
embouteillage et bien on n'émet aucune
particule
[Musique]
mais toshiba
les voix de thomas arthur ou encore
linda shelby n'ont plus de secret pour
ces lycéens aujourd'hui ce sont eux qui
doublent les personnages de la célèbre
série picchi blenders une initiative de
leur professeur d'anglais et du
réalisateur yvelinois benjamin tal y est
maintenant toutes les nouvelles
générations sont très passionnés par ce
genre de choses avec tout le tous les
réseaux sociaux qui existent ils pas se
mettre en scène facilement donc quand on
leur propose de se mettre en scène
derrière un micro devant une caméra ils
sont très contents ils voient encore
plus l'importance de de l'oral
finalement
avoir la correction la prononciation de
l'intonation aussi qui est très très
importante donc je crois que c'est
encore plus concret et motivant pour le
travail de la langue deux micros un
enregistreur et une bande rythmo projeté
sur le tableau cette salle de classe
prend le temps d'un instant les allures
d'une salle d'enregistrement
une expérience qui change des cours
habituels ça change de l'ordinaire et ça
permet d' un peu changé sa voix ça
permet de vivre d'autres personnages
c'est clairement la meilleure façon
d'apprendre une façon ludique et à la
fois qui vraiment nous pousse à
travailler parce qu'on est obligés de
s'entraîner pour la prononciation et
franchement et en plus on prend vraiment
là un accent anglais britannique
véritable ce qui compte c'est d'être
intéressés et à partir du moment où le
professeur est capable de capter
l'attention de l'élève sa porte beaucoup
et je pense que là dessus travaille
différemment amener de nouvelles
pédagogies permet effectivement de
pouvoir promouvoir l'anglais l'occasion
aussi de faire connaître le travail de
comédien de doublage une profession
encore méconnu qui n'est pourtant pas
dénué de complexité ce qui est compliqué
c'est déjà la technique vocale donc la
bande rythmo à suivre qui peut être très
rapide à certains moments selon le
rythme du jeu de voix du personnage à
l'écran et puis la transformation de la
voix aussi on le voit pas trop c'est
quand même à des gens derrière l'écran
mais c'est vrai que c'est assez
compliqué au quotidien de faire ça
efforts vains sacré talent je pense pour
ça quand on voit le travail c'est
quelque chose surtout que là on a fait
des scènes de quelques minutes et quand
on se dit qu'il ya plusieurs films et où
c'est qu'à mon travail des ateliers qui
porteront leurs fruits à la fin de
l'année le grand oral du baccalauréat
est prévue du lundi 20 juin au vendredi
21 juillet 2022
[Musique]
pour conclure cette édition le palmarès
du guide michelin 2022 dévoilé ce mardi
une nouvelle entrée dans les yvelines
celle du grand contrôle qui gagne sa
première étoile cet hôtel-restaurant de
versailles s'est offert les services
d'alain ducasse le chef y propose son
festin un voyage culinaire au xviiie
siècle au temps des rois les six autres
établissements évinois déjà présent dans
le guide michelin conservent leur étoile
versailles est bien représentée avec le
gordon ramsay au trianon et la table du
11 pour le reste la table des blu à
dampierre le village à marly-le-roi
numéro trois au tremblay sur mauldre et
le panoramique un rôle boise au total
sept restaurants désirent une figure
dans le célèbre guide gastronomique avec
une étoile départements franciliens le
mieux loti hors paris belle soirée sur
tv 78
[Musique]